stories are equipment for living it's to
give us a deeper and deeper
understanding of what is absurd and
comic and what is tragic and dark and
painful whatever to see the full
spectrum of life
beyond anything we could possibly live
the wonderful thing about story
is it's a museum if you wish you could
go back and and read the Odyssey or The
Iliad Mark Twain and Tolstoy it's all
there waiting for you and every one of
those great works is as valid today as
it was when it was written the story
expands your humanity and it also
enriches your understanding of of how
and why people in the world
do the things they do to equip you to
live more more successfully